we will present an offer to the British
people which will be remain in the EU as
it is hopefully with some reforms in the
future but also leave but maintaining a
trade relationship a customs union
obviously maintaining the open border
between Northern Ireland and the
Republic and dynamic relationship on
consumer rights environmental
protections and rights at work I think
that's a good offered by people and that
I say they are not getting at the moment
I totally understand that but what I'm
trying to understand as a voter as a
member of the public is what do you
believe what do you want do you want to
leave with a negotiated exit that you
negotiate that protects jobs or do you
actually believe that we should remain
in the EU the bottom line is protecting
jobs and living standards in a trade
relationship with Europe that is my
bottom line the offer is either you
continue within the European Union and
there are obviously many people are very
upset with the European Union look at
the referendum result or we have the
deal that we can achieve with the
European and I and I and I think that is
a sensible position but has logical
party as a leader what do you believe
what do you want the best for the
British people and the best arrangements
we can get so that we maintain our trade
relationships and our living standards
but above all that we bring people and
communities and the country together
we're riven with the most horrible
divisions because of the behavior partly
of our government and others over this
we have to bring people together and I
think our offer can do that finally just
one more thing Boris Johnson's clear he
wants to leave Nigel Faraj absolutely
wants to leave a clean brexit or no deal
Jos wince and doesn't just want to
remain she now wants to overturn the
referendum I don't know whether you want
to stay or go
I want the choice to be made by the
British people and I will deliver it you
don't want to tell me I want to tell you
that I will deliver the decisions made
by the British people I won't
negative the Rev the referendum result
in the way the Liberal Democrats do and
I won't take us over a cliff in the way
the Boris Johnson does